the brooklyn nets are 35 and 36 they've
won three straight
five of their last six karis levert
drives on collins
that's what he can do as well defensive
rating has not been too bad for the
brooklyn nets
they're number nine oh revert hit as he
fires counting for two and a foul
up the foul high screen and roll with
allen and then from the back side it
looked like
mccullum got a piece of that body of
levert sending him to the free-throw
line right there
reggie when you think of the play it has
not stopped his ability to run the floor
lever tried to shove that ball in here
they come now with mccollum off
delivered
speed look at the guy ellen it's up and
in by damien lillard
and lillard with the two six so far
from a column and chiseling inside
levert
karis leverch got seven all could play
with a broken bone in our back
how about announcing with a broken bone
in your brain i wouldn't be here here's
laverne
three [ __ ] nice he has been treated
daily and i texted him asking him if
there was any concern moving forward
he said i'm not worried now i can worry
about it in off season it's no good by
justin anderson who's five years out of
uva
[Music]
oh libertal drive look at him crashing
someone can get the two
damian lillard timeout taken by brooklyn
collins up top johnson is following
back out there here's dane four assists
already tough three
good what a shot by lillard how cold
this shot is
by lillard look where the defense is
there's not enough air speed by tyler
johnson
they get a two stepped on the line
pretty shot
millard 30 footers and wow a big bomb
outside by
damian lillard i mean this is from look
how far he is
wow here comes levert he's got 10 with
six assists
his passing has been great got the
screen
he probes and fires karis levert
12.
and by the way there's a guy named kd
ready to come in after his achilles is
healed
laverne hits the shot oh what gonna
happen that means they're going to beat
the la lakers
in the first round right and possibly
beat the clippers in the
conference final here's a drive-by team
rebound by simons out to mccullum rather
to
lillard who's got 16 points driving
through traffic sifting his way for two
they're so worried about that high
screening role in him knocking down
those 30-footers
lillard with 16. inside they go
and pulling the trigger here's levert
7-13 makes a move makes the fake and
puts one up
crawls in for two we start
the second half collins is out on charis
levert with a drive through two
defenders and he got it
pretty play getting skinny inside karis
levert
brooklyn has got nine more points above
the arc
second chance points favoring portland
gallon shot
my goodness what a beauty right there by
lillard
all you got to do is shake this man's
hand little step back falling
out of bounds harris contests the shot
in the nba number one and
over 42 lillard from that kind of
distance
levert dancing back and forth with the
drive
shot clock with which to work still 58
shooting for brooklyn
once again 26.
[Applause]
here comes levert who roots with the
screen
screen by allen doubled his levert
devon booker was pulling for his guy
tyler johnson
dame slices for two first time for
brooklyn
that's it out scored portland in this
quarter 35-19
and a minute to go lillard
[Applause]
dead center that was taken from
corvallis
wow what a shot four-point game comes
damien lillard 33.
works on jeremiah martin puts up another
three and he puts it in
it's too late nurkic has space and fires
on the floor
picked up by carmelo lillard three
bullseye
this is papa shot people well wahoo
cabarro
has got 19. working his way inside
nice little move two right there by
karis levert and garrett trent jr is
reluctant
revert with trent on him
oh a series of fakes in this beautiful
and he gets the two on that move
turkic has got 20. levert's got 32
spinning inside fatal good he's got
almost
34. he's willing another offensive
rebound allen
volleyballed it back a new shot clock to
work with here comes levert
in doubled up in town oh what a play
paris levert second shot opportunity
here for the nets
and it's levert
lukaris lavert with five seconds left
levert
going for the win his jumper no
no good portland wins and escapes
to clinch the 8th c
is an opportunity as the nets go for the
win
that will forever continue to motivate
him and drive the player we know karis
levert to be
[Applause]
didn't want to extend the game
said he was going to win or go home
and lavert
could not quite get it to go as damien
lillard looks around at the clock and
knows
we've done it